[Music]
what's up brawls my name's pan pan and
we got Latin Adam Adam oh we're playing
recurring nightmares uh April 7 1884
Biff April blah blah blah I really don't
care I'm sorry this place is really cool
I mean we got alcohol great awesome
no alcohol in them but you know and
another Latin a time minimum we already
get the lantern so it's good it's good I
like when I start off with the with the
language whoa what the [ __ ] was that
ah why me why me why did I do I haven't
done anything I'm just gonna go sivanna
video what the [ __ ] is going on I just
woke up what's going on I don't know
either Savannah but ah nope
[ __ ] that I'm not going there sorry
Stefan how about dropping you okay
here's nothing no okay I'm not really
feel like I got the right have to say to
blah blah blah blah Martin Martin ma
Dean Reuther
what the [ __ ] ah oh what's going on here
Oh breath oh [ __ ] if I like okay I just
gotta pick up the Latin Adam um ma
didn't
[ __ ] this [ __ ] mod [ __ ] it in the
[ __ ]
this penetrated deeply okay
where's the fauna okay it's you me buddy
its freakin go let's freakin get the
hell out of here
ha ha
nope
you go first Ivana you go [ __ ] first
okay let's pick this up I'm not here for
you I'm here for the note I have
definitely been here before but there's
must be another way out to throw that
home it didn't look like it worked out
like well for the others dried it not
didn't I'm not doing with everybody much
Denzil screever Yeomans really about out
okay good okay pity
let's get that ah he's right there be
careful
I uh get Scully here too but whatever
Stefano is awesome er plus he's golden
addition son hello oh my god so many
barrels so many freakin barrels look at
those barrels to fauna we're screwed for
sure
oh [ __ ] is right there what's he doing
okay let's go feeding this way I know
you hate battles but tried to hold it
I hate barrows hey barrels
oh [ __ ] okay this is wait em out
I hate you I hate you on gays leaving
he's definitely me alright
this girl's the fauna Oh what the [ __ ]
oh he's alive
I get his nipples I like what is he
doing Stephano all you like when I do
this oh it's like surprise match is
sivanna okay I want to twist his nipples
like no no I got bit by nipples I'm
doing on a crystal I gotta do it up new
okay
holy [ __ ] even cop one [ __ ] barrels
knew you were talking to him I saw it
okay let's go Stephano you're my only
friend Stefano I know I know I know I
know I am French that's okay
as long as about as long as I thought it
was go huh
wael anymore
oh man I'm glad to have you buddy I'm
really [ __ ] light uh man that was
awesome
what are you talking about it was an
awesome ha ha that was a pretty sweet
jump though which way only dual Adolphe
king kelana cough you want to do
Stephano shell I can do it
Ola doula Duff king kelana you're too
slow
let's just go here are you [ __ ]
kidding me oh oh oh he was prefer ah ah
ah barrels the distance is to foster job
I knew that sivanna I'm gonna place it
on the barrel right it's over here
it's the same right yeah okay let's see
if we can use this barrels [ __ ] hate
barrels they look pretty good on that
barrel though Savannah Thank You Billy
I've been working out that's not what I
meant but whatever oh wow
get this no no oh come on
that was like my only way out of here
yeah I'm [ __ ] I could just go down
here and kill myself
oh [ __ ]
I get up [ __ ]
okay after we do that I hope the planks
is still there now you have to count I
hope the follow is still there
I need him okay I don't have Stefano now
I'm really sad yes Devon oh I love it ay
I waited for y'all when did you go okay
let's be more careful live with this
rotate it but not make it hit something
why I didn't mean that
I'm sorry Sivan oh I'm sorry
maybe we'll find them again left okay
okay beef okay beautiful 360 holy [ __ ]
that was awesome if that wasn't worth
alike I don't know what's worth alike
okay don't although [ __ ] I hate babies
I mean I don't hate them but I when
they're make noises
what the [ __ ]
he killed the bro if I can kill the bro
he's really horny I mean he really wants
me like I think we need to go here
oh good I meet it happy of course
[Music]
oh [ __ ] he sees me
okay we're good
and don't have any tuna boxes a shilling
Bruce proud my lantern oh [ __ ] this mod
is so [ __ ] scary okay okay I go out
without my line and it's cool it's cool
oh yeah okay I was perverse it was
professed it was this prefers hello
[ __ ] this [ __ ] mob seriously though
Scully I'm [ __ ] taking you with me I
don't care oh man ah I'm diggin you down
there bro April 5th 1987 I reached a
dark room with a hole in the door for I
think I remember digging it yet my hands
are even dirty when the darkness falls
I will try escaping this hellish Manson
through it mutton mutton oh we're here
ah is that you much Jen what the hell
did they do they Oh did it review Oh
Martin ma didn't nobody Martin with
their Oh so we either go now I can't
even go there up the stairs up the
stairs up the stairs is there okay
get no over here
mutton mapped in look at your penis bra
April 23 1887 the floor and we office is
like I remember something about the key
next to a well I cannot go family I need
to lice mutton oh ok key next to a well
I know what that is I know ladies I'm
children my hey okay okay I got this no
problemo there was well here so there's
gotta be a key yes yeah okay
nothing creepy about this we have the
key we can continue in this frickin mod
okay I'm actually jumping up the Cyrus
that's how elite I am ye okay that was
the 180 so that wasn't really cool or
anything but whatever
don't judge me don't don't don't judge
my 360s like judge whatever you want but
don't you dare judge me
the [ __ ] happened there
I don't trust you
I don't trust you either actually I'm
gonna do like this I don't trust double
trust I'll crap maybe this one
yay key to freedom what's going on here
huh huh I have to go there oh I have to
go there oh man oh man oh man just
you're on the ball oh but I can't boat
I'm out okay bro
okay oh [ __ ] I nearly made it I can
pinch this told oh I'm pinching his
stuff I'm doing it
there's no escaping my fungi bone your
penis I mean on your pattern of mine
mutton mutton you may be working off for
now but every time you close her eyes
you will be back in my domain so it room
okay sorry sorry about that anyway hope
you enjoy that was really scary that was
really good ah [ __ ] walking paradox
no I'm not
three seas with a [ __ ] Triceratops
Reptar rapping as I'm [ __ ] deaf rock
stars mine synthetic wigs made of an
wash shred